After months of radio silence, Solo has finally
burst onto the scene.
The new Star Wars story is the first of Disney's
spinoff films set to explore the life of an
original trilogy character — in this case
the smuggler Han Solo, played for the first
time by Alden Ehrenreich.
Between the Super Bowl teaser and the first
trailer, there's a lot to digest.
Here are a few details you might have missed.
New duds
Han Solo having more or less the same costume
in the original three Star Wars movies and
The Force Awakens made many fans assume they
would be seeing young Solo sporting the exact
same look in his standalone film.
But that's not the case: in the Solo trailer,
the young pilot is instead sporting a wide
variety of interstellar fashions.
New ships
The end of the trailer provides one of the
most striking images yet from the new Star
Wars movies: a Star Destroyer in a dense nebula
dispatching some TIE Fighters in pursuit of
the Millennium Falcon.
While we don't know the names of these new
ship models yet, you can see that there's
an extra laser-shooting pod to the side of
the cockpit, presumably for extra firepower.
New locale
While the trailer doesn't identify exactly
where in the galaxy this chase is taking place,
speculation is already swirling that the pursuit
may be set near the cloudy area of Kessel,
which, according the Extended Universe, is
surrounded by a cluster of black holes.
It stands to reason that those opaque gases
would be dangerous to navigate and would make
any ship passing through it hard to detect
— key attributes for, say, a smuggler's
route.
That's why many fans are speculating that
this footage could be of the famous Kessel
Run, which Solo made in just 12 parsecs, not
14, as Rey claims in The Force Awakens.
New droid
If you've been combing through these clips
looking for actress Phoebe Waller-Bridge,
look no further.
She plays this charming droid, L3-37, who
seems to be the Millennium Falcon's co-pilot.
She doesn't speak in the trailer, so the tone
of the droid is still unknown.
She definitely seems to be one of the good
guys, and even has a nice little synchronized
salute with Lando, played by Donald Glover.
New Falcon
How many times did you have to watch the trailer
before you realized this bright clean hallway
belonged to the Millennium Falcon?
By the time Luke comes on board the ship in
A New Hope, the place looks positively grimy.
Fans knew Solo would show us how the smuggler
acquired the iconic vessel, but who knew it'd
look like it was straight off the assembly
line?
New baddies
Han Solo goes literal space cowboy in his
first adventure, facing down a squad of bad-looking
bandit dudes with nothing but his famous blaster
at his side.
Exactly where this showdown is taking place
is still a very hidden detail, but he's certainly
not fighting the Empire here.
This encounter is outlaw-on-outlaw, and it
looks like the same baddies take on Han on
top of a train at one point in the film.
New genre
The new trailer also provides audiences their
first look at Thandie Newton playing a gun-toting,
no-nonsense lady named Val.
She's introduced in a brief clip while Woody
Harrelson's space pirate Tobias Beckett is
talking about getting a team together.
Director Ron Howard has previously described
Solo as a heist movie, though we don't know
yet what's being stolen and why.
From the look of Newton's gigantic gun, her
character's probably what you'd call "the
muscle."
New critter
The trailer also features a blink-and-you'll-miss-it
appearance by this little creature, a four-armed
space monkey piloting some heavy machinery.
It's hard to guess just how this alien critter
will figure into the story, but considering
the dingy environment, it looks like he might
be messing around in the Spice Mines of Kessel,
doing some dirty work with some sort of monkey-sized
machinery.
New partner
Here we see Emilia Clarke's mysterious Qi'ra
sitting side-by-side with Han travelling through
what appears to be an Imperial base while
enemies follow in hot pursuit.
In our first glimpse of Qi'ra in the teaser,
and in all her red-caped glory in the trailer,
she appeared to be a straight-laced, stylish
figure of authority.
But here she looks like an outlaw, the Bonnie
to Han's Clyde.
Does he romance her out of an Imperial position
of authority?
Or has she always been a scoundrel at heart?
Either way, she's definitely on the run, but
she's got luck on her side — check out Han's
gold dice hiding in plain sight.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!